Twitter has been very upset about this
very strange headline from PC Gamer here
which is fair enough but I've not
actually clicked to read the article it
says ratchet Clank Rift apart is great
on PC but at 60 for a 10 hour story it's
not as easy to recommend as we'd like
I'm in agreement is a nut take uh I
don't think video games should be valued
um in accordance with how long they are
but I think it's difficult to judge
value in reviews anyway this is an issue
that I always had when I was a
journalist is like but is it worth this
amount of money because different
amounts of money are worth different
things to different people right so like
I'm happy to spend ninety dollars a
hundred and ten dollars in Australia as
I did on AAA video games I'm not willing
to spend
300 on a dress my sister who probably
happily spend 300 on a dress but can't
justify spending 100 on a video game so
when you talk about value of like is it
worth 20 is it worth sixty dollars I
don't think that makes any sense because
I think it depends on you as a person
and how much you value I think even even
like if I want to get real picky about
it even recommending people games is
really hard because anytime someone's
like hey I'm looking for a new game to
play on my PlayStation 5 what do you
recommend I'm like what games do you
like this there's so much in that
question so it's difficult to say sixty
dollars for a ten hour story doesn't
work for a mass Market recommendation
that is six dollars an hour which I
think is pretty good especially because
I think Ratchet and Clank Rift apart is
a fantastic game but if you're only
recommending Things based on how long
they are then of course you're like only
gonna recommend wow or Baldur's Gate
three the genre of which doesn't appeal
to so many people so yeah like
fundamentally disagree with this tweet
and understand why they're getting eat
for it I don't understand either parts
of it but I also want to say
for me personally which is like the
opposite of what PC Gamer is going for
here uh who I are an outlet that I I
don't pay a ton of attention to games
media these days but I feel like like
rarely have disagreeable takes a 10-hour
story is massively appealing to me I am
more likely to finish something if it's
10 hours than if it's 70 hours I mean
statistically that applies to every
player right so I'm more likely to buy
it if it's a very good 10 hours than if
it's an up and down hundred hours right
yeah 10 is also not even that short like
when I was spending my whole life
playing video games obviously just I
still
do a lot but when I was a teenager and I
didn't have other responsibilities like
a full-time job games averaged about 12
hours like I think Uncharted one is
probably like 12 hours like that era of
video games was much shorter Uncharted
how long to be Uncharted Drake's Fortune
is about eight hours main plus sides is
nine and a half Uncharted two honor
among Thieves ten and a half hours 12
and a half hours for me games used to be
way shorter and it made them easier to
make now when every game is 20 plus
hours and that's like the expectation
where reviews are concerned that's why
it takes Triple A debcycle five plus
years it's half a decade now because
this expectation that like this game
can't be
10 hours that seems so nuts to me I mean
let's see like the best other best games
of that era be BioShock
how long to beat
12 hours now would you be like not what
60 bucks and he isn't that nuts like
considering how short Bioshock is again
compared to some Modern games
how much that 12 hours sits with you
slash has sat with everybody how long is
Metal Gear Solid that's a great question
I don't remember how long to be 11 and a
half hours same thing I would say for
Metal Gear Solid and BioShock
these are like incredible gaming
experiences
that feel like they sit with you your
whole life because the hours are so good
and I would way prefer that than
something that gets bloated and taken to
be just just blown up to be much bigger
solely so that devs can uh have a longer
game length because obviously press
always asks and then
people get outraged uh so the review
says this colorful action adventure is
the quintessential console exclusive
released for the PlayStation 5 in 2021
it takes a beloved Duo of Sony mascots
and sends them on a journey designed to
show off these specific capabilities of
that Hardware particularly I always win
that one really hard in the accent
particularly particularly that's right
isn't it particularly it's fast loading
SSD showcased with a story all about
hopping seamlessly between universes all
of which makes it a bit of an oddity to
be reviewing on PC in 2023. I'm a fan of
more gameplay oriented reviews I mean I
think it's a really good point here that
they're making which is that it is odd
to review A PS5 launch title that was
clearly
from my perspective designed to sell
ps5s on PC that's a weird state to be in
and can be acknowledged I think I'm good
with mentioning it but not being in the
whole review I guess same I'm fine with
mentioning and say whatever you want to
make it sound like it's the big takeaway
is uh something that I do fundamentally
disagree with uh between regular bouts
of third person shooting and light
platforming you're thrown into
extravagant scent pieces lavish boss
fights and lovingly crafted cutscenes
with a little exploration and puzzle
solving for spice rally is it taxing but
it isn't dull for a PS5 player in 2021
it was an easy recommendation with its
slick big budget visual visuals and
buttery smooth performance it was a
solid if frothy exclusive a theme park
Rider show off what Sony's Hardware
could do on PC in 2023 well my feelings
are a little more complicated and though
it doesn't run quite as smoothly as it
did on PS5 Rift apart remains a lovely
way to push your Hardware visual
spectacle is The Game's greatest
strength combining technical Wizardry
with a gorgeously exuberant art style to
create scenes of Vistas that are no less
impressive for being two years old and
it is a really good looking game though
the story hardly plums complex emotional
depths you'll certainly find yourself
empathizing with the central cast a lot
more than you have expected to with a
furry-faced alien or a robot this size
of a lunchbox every combat encounter has
a glorious visual chaos the basic
shooting is very straightforward there's
no cover the aiming is very generous so
you're just free to run around blasting
without much need for tactical thinking
what adds color is a huge arsenal of
wild and wacky weapons which is one of
the ways that I feel like ratchet Clan
cryptopot succeeds it didn't need to be
that creative it's super creative though
many of these feel a bit restrained
considering the goofiness of the guns
it's disappointing for example the first
major milestone for a weapon that
literally blasts enemies into pixelated
versions of themselves it's just they're
a little bit more likely to drop Health
when they die see this is a fair
criticism
we agree with um not necessarily agree
with it but we we are
supports this criticism it sounds like
the critters had one issue with the
length which got overblown by Twitter
I'm in agreement actually so I think
this is a well-written review thus far
this is Tara they're talking about the
things they like and the things they
don't like it's possible someone else
wrote the headline that happened when I
worked at IGN
that somebody else could have written it
or somebody else wrote the tweet
but I imagine that they'll get to the
length at some point this course not
lining up with article bro shocking I
feel like every time pretty much that
Twitter is like really upset about a
headline they did not read the article
it makes sense people on Twitter just
evaluate if the headline confirms their
bias and retweet definitely people
pretty much everywhere do that and it
sucks working your way through
everything riftopod has to offer is
gentle but satisfying experience no
enemy is that hard to beat no
collectible is that convoluted to find
and there's plenty of mechanical and
visual variety to prevent you getting
bored as a weekend of cinematic
adventure and pleasant ticking off of
tasks it's really endearing so this is
where we get into the meat of that
criticism I suppose the problem is that
even collecting absolutely everything
doing every side quest and fully
upgrading every gun in addition to
completing the main story
only took me about 15 hours total if you
just Mainline the critical path it'll be
10 hours or less there's a new game plus
mode with further levels of weapons too
with further levels of weapon upgrades
to gain but while I enjoyed my time with
Rift apart there certainly isn't enough
depth to compel me to immediately replay
it that is also a fair criticism I just
don't know about this one man
and it does seem like it is the Crux of
their of their beef gravity is no bad
thing in games
okay
but it's hard to escape the sense that
Rift apart is a console showcase that
feels far less vital on PC also okay
this is an important sentence that again
definitely gets lost in the Twitter
discourse uh though it came out six
months after the PS5 it has all the
Hallmarks of a launch game designed to
reveal the hardware can do at a point
where not many other options are
available agree with that it's great
looking and likable you'd have to be
pretty conventionally not to get some
joy out of its colorful Galaxy but it's
far more style than substance
at 50 pounds sixty dollars it's hard to
escape the fact that on PC there are
bigger media experiences you could put
that money towards that's interesting
so that if the final note there is like
there's so many games on PC
you can get things that are longer
if you want a nice flashy faction
platformer that's correct but I don't
know that that's um I ultimately
disagree with the take but feel like the
article is
very well written and well reasoned and
and you are entitled to say It
ultimately
um there's always a bigger game there is
always a meteor game Ratchet and Clank
for what it is which is casual fun
colorful light-hearted I think is like
effectively perfect at doing that yeah
and 80 score is not bad either like an
80 is not terrible in fact this makes it
sound like it's gonna be a lot more
harsh than an eight it's a shame yeah I
wonder if that was like social media